معنى من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي سياده العميد هناك
امور كثيره يعني ربما يجب ان اسال عنها
ولكن اريد ان ابدا من هجوم المسيرات ربما
لم يتخيل الروس لعقود ان يصل هجوم على احد
ابراج موسكو وهذا ما اقتربت منه اوكرانيا
اليوم عن طريق المسيرات الى اي مدى هذا
الامر مهم من الناحيه العسكريه
عثمان من الناحيه العسكريه اصبح نمطا
اوكرانيا استهداف مركز الثقل من وزارات من
مراكز الاعمال وحتى الكريم اليوم او صباح
اليوم هذا الهجوم يبعد 500 كم تقريبا عن
الكريم فاذا نحن امام مرحله جديده ولكن
لماذا هذا الاستهداف حتى لو سقطت دون اي
ضرر عثمان هي ضربه سيكولوجيه تظهر شاشه
الدفاع عن موسكو وهذا الامر يعود الى
المنظومه الدفاعيه حول موسكو التي تعود
الى التسعينات يعني هناك ما يسمى
هذه الدائره الكبرى تغطي كل المدينه فيها
100 صاروخ للصواريخ النوويه على دائره
اصغر هناك صواريخ مع الرذارات مع القياده
الوسطى ايضا لديها صواريخ
قصيره المدى متوسطه وبعيده مدى ولم يذكر
في اي تخطيط ما المخاطر من المسيرات لان
عدد هذه الجهازيه معده كي لا تشتغل اثناء
تحليق من الطيور او ما شابه فاذا نحن امام
مرحله جديده لا يمكن لروسيه ان تدافع عن
موسكو بشكل جيد واصبح لاوكرانيا صناعه
مسيرات متقدمه جدا جدا عثمان سيد الياس مع
هذه الاسلحه التي تمتلكها الان اوكرانيا
وبالتالي هذا ينعكس على التكتيكات
الاوكرانيه كما كنت تتحدث على روسيا بماذا
تقابل ذلك موسكو باي تكتيك لمواجهه الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد وهنا ما يسمى
مفارقه يعني الجيش الاوكراني درب على
القتال المشترك للاسلحه دبابات مدفعيه
طيران هندسه مدرعات وما شابه ولكنه لم
يعطى
التكمله الاساسيه الطيران وهنا نتحدث عن
الاف 16 يعني هو انت تطلب من الجيش
الاوكراني ان يقاتل قتال مشترك لخلق
الدفاعات الروسيه وطائرات بعد فتره
صح ولكنك لا تعطيه الوسائل اللازمه من هنا
غيرت اوكرانيا التكتيك وبدل ان تخرق في
مكان واحد وتضع الجهد الرئيسي في مكان
واحد وسعت الهجومات على ثلاثه محاور
اساسيه الابسط 12 غنوه لن تكون جاهزه الا
في مارس 2024 يعني هناك ثمانيه ثمانيه
طيارين يتكلمون انجليزيه هم يتدربون الان
عليها وهناك عشرين طيار في بريطانيا
للتعلم على الانجليزيه وبعدها فاذا نحن
نتحدث عن اقل من نصف سرب يعني هناك
24 طائره لكل سرب ثمان طيارين نصف سرب من
15 يعني كي تدخل في المعادله للسنه
القادمه من هنا تعذر تحقيق شيء وهذا ما
يؤكده التقرير الاستخباراتي التي نشرته
الواشنطن بوست الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
كثيرا ما تم الحديث عن كونه بطيئا ومؤخرا
عن انه لن
يحقق الاهداف المرجوه في شبه جزيره القرم
او الجسر البري وما الى ذلك ولكن دعني
اسالك ما هو ما حققه هذا الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد
عثمان تقدم بسيط كيلومترات او مئات
الكيلومترات البسيطه باستثناء مخموط ولكن
على مسافه يحتلها الجيش الروسي من تقارب
120 الف كيلو متر عشرين بالمئه من الاراضي
الروسيه اليوم بدل الاوكراني تكتيكه وذهب
الى التماس على خطوط التماس 900 كيلومتر
ولكن مع ضرب العمق اللوجستي للقوات
الاوكرانيه من هنا منذ يومين بدا استهداف
العمق الغربي في اوكرانيا لكل القواعد
العسكريه لكل المخازن العسكريه التي تحوي
على سلاح غربي خاصه الطيران الذي يستعمل
الذي يستعمل
الانجليزي او الاسكلب الفرنسي والذي يضرب
العمق اللوجسدي في شبه جزيره القرم شكرا
جزيلا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي